eine prinzessin
ja das ist doch das nicht übel
du musst starke ohne neben der nase zu
worden herzlich willkommen in meinem
tollen will die kleine familie heute
schon begrüßt und heute möchte ich das
gewinnspiel verlosen was ja letzte woche
begonnen hat das gegen von 8 bis 14
august und ich hatte zahlreiche
teilnehmer vorerst möchte ich mich aber
auch bei allen bedanken die sich so sehr
für die kitchenaid interessiert haben
also das hätte ich niemals gedacht dass
da wirklich so viele leute ist eine
kitchenette stellen was mittlerweile
habe ich so um die 30 40 bestellungen
und jeden tag kommen neue bestellungen
dazu ich finde es wirklich cluster wird
euch die maschine so gut gefällt
ich möchte auf jeden fall in der
nächsten tagen noch ein video dazu
machen was die kitchenaid vorteile hat
gegenüber anderen küchenmaschinen ich
möchte auch mal mit dem thermomix
vergleichen weil viele mir die frage
stellen warum soll ich mir den kindern
älteren thermomix kaufen und das mache
ich einfach in einem extra video und
wird euch da eben die frage beantworten
jetzt soll die kleine glücksfee die
gewinner allzu land habe
etwa 2000 teilnehmer ihr konnte
natürlich bei youtube und bei facebook
mitmachen kann bei youtube fans etwa 800
kommentare bei facebook über 900 und
dann hatte ich noch etwa knapp etwas
mehr als 300 die eben bei facebook den
kommentar oder diesen kurs geteilt haben
ich finde es einfach wahnsinnig
ursprünglich wollte ich soziales per
hand schreiben aber ich habe einfach
nicht gedacht dass es wirklich so viele
werden jetzt habe ich die namen einfach
raus kopiert und dokument erstellt
ausgedruckt und habe gestern abend dann
hier diese ganzen schnitzel geschnitten
und wetter sitzt so machen dass ich
einmal ein los über youtube zehn maß
also die youtube kommentare dann die
facebook kommentare und die facebook
mithalten könnte später werden wir dann
alles vermischen und die kleine schon
ganz aufgeregt und deswegen würde ich
sagen der gletscher ab und ich möchte
einfach nicht über entscheiden welches
paket jetzt zuerst gezogen wird
deswegen habe ich jetzt 14 gemacht habt
die zahlen eins bis vier die samira geht
jetzt einen zettel 10 und somit dann
bestimmen das eben jetzt zum beispiel
fürs päckchen nummer eins gezogen wird
und danach würde ich sagen starte ich
mit den youtube kommentar dann die
facebook an am totalen länger die
facebook den inhalt geteilt haben und
später werden wir eben wie gesagt alles
zusammen mischen und daneben das letzte
päckchen verloren
jetzt musste mir einen zettel geben
gehen wir mal eine den da also losen wir
jetzt zuerst päckchen nummer zwei auf
das heißt das ist dieses päckchen hier
mit dem ausrollen mit der citrus presse
mit den vier farben der modelliert und
soweit es durch mich einmal mission
nein das nicht früher mal durch man kann
so mischen kannst dich super fertig und
jetzt gibt es mir einen zettel
irgendeinen konto und einen heilen gibst
du mir jetzt päckchen nummer zwei hat
gewonnen
keine ahnung wie man es ausspricht emi
label anne may be able keine ahnung auf
jeden fall dass du das päckchen nummer 2
gewonnen
herzlichen glückwunsch machen wir weiter
hier findest du mir das wiedergeben
das brauchen wir gleich noch mal
jetzt gehen wir mal eine zeit informiert
so mal einen aus einem kriminellen
geschäft und du wirst weiter so jetzt
losen wir päckchen nur drei aus es war
das päckchen mit dem gerbera ausstecher
hier das ist die das vergisst mit römer
durch und dann gibt's nur wieder einen
zettel eine nun zwei hat gewonnen
frank wallau jetzt ziehen wir das
päckchen nur eins also dass mit dem
jetzt immer wieder hand durch die eben
bei facebook den post geteilt haben
jetzt gibst du mir 1 dieses päckchen hat
gewonnen
den heftigsten klick von mir gestern von
der smarte gestochen deswegen hört sie
von dickes augen bürger noch mal wieder
zu also päckchen nummer vier wird jetzt
beziehungen jetzt müssen wir alles
zusammen
eins steht also päckchen nummer vier ein
gutschein für die wandtattoos hat
gewonnen
michaela wunderlich herzlichen
glückwunsch an alle gewinner
vielen dank an alle die mitgemacht haben
ich denke ich mache schon gewünscht wird
noch mal irgendwann vielleicht bei 20
oder 30.000 und 50.000 abonnenten immer
schauen auf jeden fall habe ich mich
wirklich sehr dass ich so viele
beteiligt haben angeblich nur jeden von
euch gewinnen lassen weil ich einfach
toll finde mich unterstützt ihr schaut
meine videos ihr werdet die gibt mir
kommentare und feedback anregungen
respekt wünsche und ohne euch weil das
ja alles gar nicht möglich und ohne
diese rückmeldung möchte es auch gar
nicht machen
jetzt dachte ich an mir nagt ihre
freundin spielen
die gewinner freuen sich bitte innerhalb
der nächsten fünf tage bei mir melden
falls ich in den fünf tagen nichts von
euch wäre würde ich als gewinner
auslosen
ich bin nämlich auch so lang noch die
lose auf und es wäre super wenn sich die
gewinner über youtube auch bei youtube
melden die bei facebook dann auch mal
facebook damit ich einfach
nachvollziehen kann dass sie jetzt auch
möglich sein
und ich will euch damit das päckchen zu
schicken
das heißt ihr müsst euch bei mir melden
mir eure adresse mitteilen
und dann bekommt jedes päckchen zucker
schlägt ich werde den mädchen noch immer
prägt somit rein machen
da sag ich mal ein video dazu ich möchte
nämlich ein paar coole videos machen
und jetzt wünsche ich euch noch einen
schönen kam sarah alle geben jetzt nicht
gewonnen haben aber eben sagen ihnen
dank fürs mitmachen
und du kleine